going back to the more serious
conversation i suppose the left is all
they're all staring at each other and
they i feel like most these people
actually let me stop leaked video came
out i just saw this on twitter
a teacher one of these teachers in la
you know
they do this woke stuff apparently
forgot to turn off zoom
and then went on like a racist tirade
about this other this other black family
and the way that she perceived black
people and the way they acted it was it
was crazy to hear this
and people are sharing this being like
these are the people teaching your kids
woke critical race they're
trash overtly racist they know they're
racist
they're pretending not to be racist but
they're super racist
and then it's really funny because then
you'll get black lives matter being like
yo these white people are racist
and we're like stop saying everyone's
racist but they're literally pointing to
these like
urban leftist you know critical race
theorist people too
and i'm like yeah okay well you know
those they're racist yeah for sure
that's what that's
that's what they're like behind the
scenes and they don't say it so i feel
like they're all sitting there like it's
like that uh kian peel
segment where there's where he's
sweating like crazy just like standing
there
and that's what all the like many of
these racist leftists are doing
waiting for one person to just say the
wrong word
we mix in an ex how dare you that's
offensive
women aha i got you now and they're all
just hitting each other
they don't have any real conversations
about stuff i think it's i think it's
intentional
i've been today has been very exhausting
in that
if you look at what's happening across
the world when we'll probably talk about
later crimea um
in china with hong kong and taiwan uh
russia and ukraine
like now they have the americans all
stuck in this paralyzed fiery state
so like we're not going to get involved
that's what they want if there's going
to be an invasion of
of crimea and ukraine by the russians an
invasion of taiwan and hong kong by
chinese they don't want the united
states to react in a cohesive manner
and if this is the stuff we're focused
on we're not going to bingo
yeah it feels like in many ways the
establishment
has just decided okay wokeness is our is
our path i suppose
what which it feels that way because
from the intelligence agencies to the
military even
the embracing like the chief diversity
officer or whatever
the pentagon amazing are you kidding me
why would there be a movement an effort
in the federal government to divide this
country
that sign why would why would the
americans be intentionally dividing
themselves it could either be
outside influence or it could be a form
of like
cultural apoptosis where like one cell
is no longer needed in a system it
destroys itself
so like if the united states has become
vestigial
in the human experience that we're just
we're just ending our own experience
for us i don't i don't think so i hope
not i would say this
if this is the case uh we're conquered
exactly
but okay listen people say oh i hate
division i hate division i want
to be unified but people i think
secretly love division
i make commentary if i make it very
divisive people will eat that
up people love to see their enemies
you know yeah
to own the libs we got to own the libs
and all that
i think people like the vision i think
they'd like to see their enemies hurting
they want war they want conflict of some
sort because people people
they want we're supposed to own the
communists
it's supposed to be like own the commies
you know make that anti-commie stuff and
then make fun of the communists and the
concentration camps instead we're
ripping at each other
so if if these other countries engage in
some kind of conflict if we really do
escalate in the south china sea or or in
eastern europe the us
is everyone's fighting each other so i
guess the point i'm trying to make is
we n we need to be like hey everyone in
america we come together and we respect
each other
we're all americans first we're not this
race first or this identity first
instead the the prevailing ideology
that's infected all of our institutions
from the news media to schools and now
the military
is divide everybody up based on
immutable characteristics and some other
self-identified characteristics so that
we are as fractured as possible
okay i'm sorry like any strategist is
going to be like that's a terrible idea
so that when conflict arises we're too
busy fighting ourselves
you know they want in as infantry they
want you like an infant they want your
mind clear
they don't want you to have all this
social order don't don't pull an aoc
on me there's a surge at the border
they're not insurgents they're
infantile they want to wipe your mind
clean of your past identity and make a
new one that is
synonymous with all others and that's
why you're part of this infant
this is not true
you're born and you're birthed into the
port
the people who are fighting in a
conflict who are unified who know who
who's on their side and knows what
they're fighting for
and often we have corrupt officials and
and institutions and
uh governments that manipulate the the
good will of the people who are willing
to fight and lay their lives down for
for the right cause they get manipulated
and they get exploited and that's kind
of what america has been doing for quite
some time especially in the past several
decades
but uh but but i i have tremendous
respect for those that are willing to do
that the problem is the
the corrupted system more importantly
however
when i when i see the pentagon chief
diversity officer and he got cancelled
because he had racist comments or
something i don't know amazing like
we're
we're we're infected you know what i
mean like we're fractured there's not
coming back from this is there no
you can't convince the cultist to
abandon the cult they're going to be
coming back from this we altered
globe the way humans will interact
forever yeah i thought maybe a silver
lining of covid was like people coming
together
you know no the complete opposite of
that happened
we had a common enemy here kovit and
still
nope what i absolutely love about the
covet thing too in terms of division
is that conservatives initially were
like you should wear a mask
and it was fouchy and the surgeon
general who were like no no no
and conservatives were like don't listen
don't listen and then it switched
and then what happened now the
conservatives are the ones who are like
and and the left is like where three i
was consistent on that okay there you go
there you go when the cdc and foster was
saying oh don't wear it don't wear a
mask there's no need to i was saying
you are liars you can check my twitter
were you selling gadsden flag masks i
was selling the book later
later later okay and then they switched
their mind
it was really because they didn't want
people to hoard masks they were liars
and that was terrible because now people
are not listening to them on vaccines or
anything because they're liars
however i still said hey wearing a mask
is a good idea
fauci admitted this uh in an interview
he said
we didn't want people to buy up all the
masks when the professionals needed them
first
yeah so they're a bunch of liars but now
there's a lot to a libertarian say oh
you're
you believe in these government
conspiracies because you want to wear a
mask it's like man i'm consistent on
this issue
like i'm not a child there's such a
juvenile thing like if the government
says something i'm going to do the
opposite well a lot of times that is
true but not all the time
like use your brain not just like
reactionary juvenile
i got i got hit up by somebody when all
this started going down with covid and
they were like yo the government said
you don't need masks quick buy a bunch
and i'm like is it you know what man
it's it's it's so predictable
a bunch of the libertarian type people i
know are like i don't trust the
government they're saying don't i better
buy one
and then when the government has to do
and they're like you can't tell me what
to do yeah
it's like
yeah now i'll tell you that like i
tweeted wear 12 masks
and they got like 3 000 retweets yes i
just wear 12. and people were like i
don't know 13.
it's like look i picked an arbitrary
number that was stupid yeah you know
i actually have an idea we should do
this for like a bonus thing for the
website
just put on as many mass as we can see
how many we can find yeah i just keep
playing
breathing i'm telling you i can keep
going that's huge
yeah i don't know you might get to a
point where you're like too many
men yeah like 12 might be the limit i
suppose on your elbows on your ears i
mean your ears
or have gas canals in them too do you
need to mask your ears as well you gotta
cover your eyes
no just your mouth just nose put a
pillow case over your head there you go
you can still breathe through it you
know then you're saying i saw a
commercial for those big space man
helmets
yeah they're like really taking it
seriously oh gosh of course
we have it right put your money where
your mouth is julie here you go yeah you
put on
oh yeah you're gonna be healthier when
that's over don't
you don't have to put you know how
you're gonna tell well i was really
gonna do it okay yeah they're great it's
got it
it's got an electric filter in it yeah
it's just infinitely more comfortable
wearing the space helmet than it is
wearing a mask i will say as much as
goofy as i think it is it's not
uncomfortable i mean it is uncomfortable
because it's big and heavy
i got to be honest yeah i'm gonna wear
that you know why i got allergies
yeah yeah and it's got like a hepa
filter or whatever two of them i can
walk around outside
and i won't sneeze and y'all be jealous
we're displaying the best all right
dude my allergies are bad man it's like
yeah cause all the trees are exploding
and it's basically you're getting all
this
this tree spunk up in your business
sugar and stop it it does help that
helps yeah i like it my allergies are
gone i used to get horrible
uh pollen allergies i start drinking
water cut out soda water yep yeah
and i'm no longer allergic to pollen i
can smell it if i take a huge whiff of
pollen i'll feel it tickle the back of
my throat still
but it's like dehydration it dehydrates
the nasal folds
so i drink water it kind of absorbs the
pollen i read on this website
that if you eat worms like parasites
then you'll get cured of your allergies
maybe it maybe it was just one of those
crackpot hippy dippy websites
but what it was saying was that actually
i probably saw this on reddit because i
don't read any crackpot hippie dippy
websites
but uh uh it was basically saying that
you have two different immune systems i
suppose one for parasites and one for
pathogens or something
no interesting but because we've cured
ourselves and like a limited parasites
for the most part from our diets
we just have this like crazy immune
system that could just be a bunch of
bunk nonsense
from reddit probably i don't know maybe
someone knows better so they can
try it no not me but uh you know back in
the day they used to like
like die like tape worms for diets you
would like take the pills
is that true that's true i think so i'm
i looked that up
yeah yeah and it was like tape worms
well you'll lose weight quick
they used to bleed people to try and
heal them of illness
cut their legs and and get out the bad
blood do you remember that product from
like the 2000s
where you would take a pill and then you
couldn't digest
fat yeah and you just crap it out i
remember that so
maybe was that um i remember a lot of
diet pills in the
80s and it's like you would it would
cause your body to not digest
fat and so you would just like expel it
it was like dex
something yeah yeah i don't know
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you